en este momento siete de cada diez
personas están pensando en dejar su
trabajo
las organizaciones invierten millones de
dólares en capacitar en atraer y en
desarrollar a su talento pero
lamentablemente el 70% de las personas
simplemente no se sienten satisfechas y
esto que implica pues pierde el dinero
la empresa que invirtió en ellos es un
problema muy serio para ambas partes y
esa fue la pregunta para mí cómo podemos
hacer para que tanto personas como
empresas puedan tener una situación
alineada y bueno como apasionado del
comportamiento humano no te lo voy a
poder compartir desde otra forma más que
desde una relación entre empresas y
personas te invito a que pensemos la
dinámica como una pareja la historia
sería más o menos así antes la empresa
tenía este lugar especial era el
príncipe de la película era idealizado y
prácticamente la única opción
las empresas recibían de todas las
personas sus recursos su energía se
entregaban plenamente pero era solamente
en una dirección
qué sucedió entonces las personas fueron
fracturándose a pesar de que se
incorporaba a las mujeres que es muy
importante cada vez más y nuevas
generaciones entraban al mundo
corporativo al final se hubo hubo una
fractura entre la relación empresa y
colaboradores y qué pasó se fueron y
cuando se fueron la empresa empezó a
perder capital
en este momento estas personas que
salieron del mundo corporativo y en
plena desilusión aparecen en la película
el nuevo príncipe que es el
emprendimiento el emprendimiento que
llegó con esta promesa de ser dueño de
tu tiempo vive de tus pasiones
finalmente aquí hay una alternativa y
donde creen que pusimos al
emprendimiento
arriba en el mismo lugar idealizado
donde antes estaba el príncipe
corporativo
le sucedió empezó el boom de las
startups emprendimientos ideas empezaron
a despegar sus cohetes pero que creen
resulta que solamente dos de cada diez
eran viables y entonces las demás
personas se empezaron a dar cuenta que
no era tan sencillo ni que no requería
tanto esfuerzo como el mundo corporativo
entonces las personas desconcertadas se
dieron cuenta que las empresas ni eran a
lo mejor el monstruo que creían ni el
emprendimiento era el príncipe ideal de
la película
el día de hoy estamos ante una
posibilidad de un reencuentro de estas
dos partes
es un momento en donde la empresa ya
sabe que quiere reenamorarse al
colaborador quiere atraerlo sabe que
tiene que cambiar está comunicando su
propósito sus valores pero algo está
faltando ya por un lado la empresa sabe
que si realmente le apuesta a su gente
entonces la productividad por ejemplo
aumenta en un 41% la retención del
talento un 31 por ciento y las ventas un
37 por ciento pero aún no es suficiente
que tenemos que hacer para que esta
relación realmente funcione
pues llegamos al momento de la historia
de la pareja donde decimos tenemos que
hablar
estas conversaciones que son incómodas
porque hablamos lo que todo el mundo
sabemos que sucede pero pocas veces nos
permitimos señalar
así que hay que empezar por ser 100%
responsables ni uno es el problema y el
otro es el problema hay una
responsabilidad compartida y vamos a
hablar de que le toca a cada uno en
primer lugar la empresa en este lado que
es 50% responsable empieza con un
incongruencia y todo hablar de tú a ti
líder empresario a ti
líder corporativo no está siendo
congruente con lo que dices comunicas a
tu consumidor final todo tu propósito y
el valor que agrega a tu entorno pero tu
gente no está viviendo esos valores
internamente en el fondo estás
prometiendo algo que no estás podido
sostener y tu persona te das cuenta que
tú eres el que crea ese ambiente laboral
no estás contento pero juan le tira
pedradas para la espalda
diplomáticamente en la empresa para
escalar
el líder se adorna con los logros de su
equipo en lugar de compartir el
reconocimiento esa es tu responsabilidad
la empresa genera distancia creando
líderes todavía autoritarios se reconoce
y se aprueba al líder que logró la meta
pero a costa de su gente
tú como persona seamos honestos le has
dejado toda la responsabilidad a la
empresa de tu felicidad qué estás
haciendo tú para crear tu propio
bienestar a pesar de tu entorno
empresa quieres que dure más la gente
contigo quiere enamorar los pero a la
hora de que te preguntan cual plan
tienes para mi la empresa simplemente no
tiene tanta claridad de cómo va a
desarrollar a ese talento y tú estás
delegando le pasivamente a veces el
destino a una decisión corporativa
así que qué pasa cuando hablamos lo que
nos toca esta conversación incómoda pues
tenemos que crear acuerdos nuevos
acuerdos pero estos acuerdos tienen que
ser realistas cuál es el primer acuerdo
que tiene que trabajar el corporativo la
empresa tiene que ser más congruente si
realmente esos valores para ti son
importantes contrata con base en esos
valores reconoce con base en esos
valores
empieza a darle lugar a eso que promueve
e invierte en tu gente a las personas
pues empieza a ser responsable de crear
tu entorno de tu felicidad en el trabajo
de tu bienestar con relaciones
significativas estás conectando
realmente en tu trabajo estás abriendo
te o estás haciendo lo que debes hacer
simplemente por encima tú tienes esa
responsabilidad las empresas tienen que
generar líderes cercanos más cálidos ya
no nada más excelentes profesionales
sino líderes que sepan vulnerarse con su
equipo decir necesito de ti no lo sé
todo no soy perfecto ese tipo de líderes
debes de generar que genere calidez en
tu entorno
y tu persona necesitas tener un poco más
de madurez de madurez
se tiene que madurar porque la perfecta
el perfecto trabajo al final pues no se
trata de que no tengas días malos en el
trabajo vas a tener que hacer cosas que
no te encanten pero que son necesarias
es el enfoque que tú le vas a dar
no le eches el culpa a la culpa el jefe
oa la empresa tú empieza a madurar y
entender que no hay príncipe azul en
esta historia
presa tienes que generar mayor claridad
dale más certeza a tu gente que pueden
crecer que hay un camino que realmente
lo tienes aquí bien planeado para ellos
y tu persona no le delega es tu destino
a la empresa empieza a construir tu
propósito el propósito no es algo que
encuentras es algo que construyes cómo
vas a construir de manera independiente
tu carrera
en mentores conocen nuevas personas pide
ayuda invierte recursos no nada más en
fiesta o en las comidas godín es que le
llaman invierte en tu desarrollo
personal toma ese nivel de autonomía
así que esta historia de qué cambios
estamos hablando en el fondo si los
nombramos en el término corporativo y
psicológico o humano sería a la empresa
trabaja en tu cultura interna 2 trabaja
en líderes con propósito 3 trabaja en
desarrollar un plan de vida y carrera
para tu gente y a las personas piensa de
manera más colectiva no tan individual
piensa más en dar en recibir por quedar
estadísticamente está comprobado que te
va a dar muchos más frutos el
individualismo en el trabajo tienes que
tomar una motivación intrínseca la
felicidad no la vas a encontrar si la
empresa te pone mesas de ping-pong o te
deja hacer trabajo desde casa que ya son
avances positivos hay que reconocerlo
pero la motivación más importante la más
permanente y la más trascendente es la
personal la que tú generas
así que la pregunta aquí sería es
posible es posible estos cambios esta
relación ideal alguna vez escuché eso
dice si tu visión es suficientemente
irreal entonces es suficientemente
valiosa
para mí mi visión y en lo que yo creo
firmemente es que la felicidad en el
trabajo realmente es viable yo creo que
las personas realmente se merecen
levantarse día a día motivadas a su
trabajo no por una idealización que no
es objetiva sino por una relación madura
las empresas es ese espacio estoy seguro
que habrá un día donde todos vamos a
desarrollar ese camino que no depende
nada más del emprendimiento
así que hagamos este momento de
renacimiento yo te invitaría a cuatro
cosas primero empresa tienes que
calibrar los números y la persona no se
trata de quitar los números la
rentabilidad eso es necesario para
seguir caminando pero si pones primero
el dinero antes que las personas te
estás quedando corto y no sólo eso sino
lo pones primero a la persona te estás
perdiendo de generar mayores beneficios
con tus objetivos organizacionales la
innovación la tecnología construir el
futuro es importante y la tecnología nos
va a llevar muy lejos pero solo las
ciencias humanas nos van a llevar a
todos
y tal humanismo es muy importante
pero no invitarlo nada más a una
conferencia a hablar de propósito es
invitarlo a las organizaciones de vuelta
a las instituciones de negocios hay que
volver a invitar al humanismo a
psicólogos antropólogos a filósofos no
nada más excelentes profesionistas
técnicos que sepan de negocios y por
último tener esta visión de que tu
cliente más importante no va a ser tu
consumidor final es tu gente
así que es momento de cambiar los invito
a que independientemente del lugar en
donde estés si eres líder si eres
colaborador si eres emprendedor incluso
comencemos a darle ese lugar al trabajo
ese lugar que se merece ese medio que a
todos nos va a llevar a crecer
desarrollarnos y prosperar
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]